this is an icon right here we can't say
that about everybody it is such a
pleasure to chat with you thank you i
thank you i need that iconic jacket uh i
will take this off and give it to you
right now i wouldn't want you to do that
listen when you are asked to start
with an icon as well like jane is it
immediately a no-brainer for you youtube
go way back this is not only an iconic
partnership but you are friends so long
to get you know all these jobs together
uh
but it was it's great i mean i'm glad it
happened and
and we look very seriously at something
that's offered to both of us
absolutely paul was saying you're kind
of like sisters on set he would watch
you two just have a love fest sing
together once in a while there'll be a
little fighting
yeah a little
sarcasm a little
fooling around a little embracing a
little kiss encourage you know
encouragement jane is a a
wonderful person
so let me ask you this obviously you
take away the the co-worker
title but this is a friend of yours
obviously jane let the world know what
was going on in her life so how do you
support a friend like jane during this
time
you just be there for her
i wrote her the other day and i said
please let me in jane my partner jane's
name jane too
jane won and jane's bond is jane too
that jane coined the oh my god i can't
talk about them
jane fonda coined that one and two
business
and uh and so she and she said and i
said jane
let us let jane and me do something for
you
anything and she said oh i'm fine i have
more than i need too much in fact
she's so i mean she just is down to
earth and
and
she makes a lesson of everything she
experiences
herself
she spoke to the public about
her uh can you know having lymphoma
and how she gets such great care and she
wishes everybody in the world that would
have the same opportunity as she does
um final question for you i'm a huge fan
of nine to five i know that kelly
clarkson and uh dolly parton just
released a
new version of it have you had a chance
to listen yet i haven't
you are gonna love it okay you are just
so iconic thank you so much for chatting
with us congrats on this film thank you
thank you